une commission véritablement à bout de
souffle ambiance de crise ce soir à
bruxelles l'exécutif européen est réunie
en ce moment pour tirer les conclusions
qui s'imposent après le rapport des
sages une première dans l'histoire de
l'union et la critique finalement règles
d'une véritable dérive des institutions
le président de la commission lui
connaissait depuis hier le contenu de ce
rapport récit de cette journée avec à
bruxelles pascal verneau la journée la
plus longue pour le président de la
commission européenne sourire crispé
visages permet pour jacques santer lors
de son arrivée au parlement européen
lorsqu'il reçoit officiellement le
rapport du comité des sages jacques
santer le mal-aimé sait déjà que les
critiques les plus acerbes sont un
désaveu personnel bruxelles ne contrôle
plus son administration la bousculade
des autres ces journalistes à vie qui ne
cesse de dénoncer son manque de charisme
ne le concernent plus lui-même peut-être
le sort individuel de tel ou tel
commissaire européen edith cresson
épinglé pour favoritisme l'octroi d'un
poste de visiteurs scientifique à l'un
de ses amis de châtellerault ne s'est
pas effectuée dit le rapport dans le
respect des critères de régularité alors
ce soir autour de la table collégiale
jacques santer est un homme seul que
fasse un rapport qui met véritablement
en cause l'attitude de la commission à
gérer les tâches qui lui sont confiées
par les traités et bien là la démarche
normale la conclusion normal que devrait
tirer la commission et celle d'une
démission la commission qui devrait
reprendre ses travaux en retard sur son
horaire le temps de prendre le coup
plutôt agitée des groupes du parlement
européen pour la première fois depuis
longtemps ce soir les lumières du
breydel le bâtiment des commissaires
resteront allumées une bonne partie de
la nuit